this is straban peeking out of the
mourne valley at the irish border
and just a month ago the most coveted
infected town in the uk
weeks of lockdown in northern ireland
have brought the infection rate down by
70
but the cost to the economy of strabane
and neighboring londonderry
reliant on cross-border trade and soon
to face the full effects of brexit
is harder to calculate there isn't that
spare capacity to deal with
a downturn in the city that really is
still struggling with the long-term
impacts of the closure of the shipping
industry
but yes economically as i say 2008
the economic recession was much worse in
the
areas that were already weakest derry is
the weakest economy derry and straban
are the weakest economies
in northern ireland and they will be the
ones that suffer the most
hundreds of bombings in a town of just
over 10 000 people took their toll
during decades of armed struggle against
british rule
but one shopkeeper told me this is worse
in a clothing shop across the street
another said the lights are on
but no one's buying their anxiety is
just cruising
on us when we reopened in june there was
a
certain amount of optimism of where we
were going to be in the future the next
six months
but to be sort of facing the bigger set
of problems now
and granted the time that even the time
of year that it's leading into
it's heartbreaking um but we have to
sort of raise above it and
and try and be optimistic that we will
get through it
and there will be business at the end of
this as well when the peace bridge came
to derry nearly a decade ago
it seemed to signal better times ahead
built with european union funds
connecting divided communities a
sectarian past giving way
to a european future but first brexit
and now covet 19 have put paid too much
of that
we've still haven't overcome
the fact that belfast is the dominant
part of the political culture of
northern ireland
and belfast is favored and that is an
inescapable
reality of of the western part of
northern ireland
with one in three people out of work
majority nationalist sentiment in derry
and strabane
has consigned the area to decades of
under development
and neglect there's nothing in its
immediate future
that's likely to change that joe dahl al
jazeera
derry and strabane